[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain an italian television series
called anna spoilers ahead watch out and
take care
the premise of the movie is set far in
the future in a post-apocalyptic
timeline the world has been taken over
by a deadly infectious disease called
red fever it causes red spots all over
the body and kills a person within a few
weeks its unique characteristic is that
it only kills adult humans leaving the
children unaffected however the virus
remains static in the children's bodies
and kills them after puberty when they
turn into adults it also causes
infertility which is currently
threatening the existence of mankind in
such a world a 13 year old sicilian girl
named anna lives with her five-year-old
brother astor in the middle of the woods
they survive off expired food that anna
brings from the city once in a while the
property is surrounded by barbed wire
that astor is not allowed to cross anna
has told him that the outside world has
monsters who will kill him instantly if
he gets out they have been living in
such conditions for around five years
the scene cuts to the beginning phase of
the red fever anna's parents share
custody of her but she likes her father
better one morning she and her father
are playing hide and seek in his
apartment when her mother maria barges
in she wants to take anna away to the
countryside because of the rapidly
spreading red fever although reluctant
the father allows anna to go promising
to meet her on the weekend maria's house
in the countryside is also in the middle
of the woods she lives with her
boyfriend demiano and her infant son
astor anna doesn't like either of them
because she thinks they are the reason
her parents separated maria frequently
tries to make anna get along with aster
but nothing works with the spread of red
fever turning into an alarming epidemic
maria and damiano refrain from going
into the city as much as they can but
since the disease hasn't been seen in
their city yet anna and astor go to
school regularly one day the teachers at
school are diagnosed with red fever
which causes chaos the parents come to
take their children back home and be
safe maria is called several times but
she doesn't pick up because she is busy
making love to damiano in the end only
anna and astor are left alone with no
word from their parents who says sex
can't be dangerous a kind teacher named
angel decides to give them a ride home
although she doesn't know their address
anna tries to guide her through the
streets but since the house is in the
middle of the woods they get confused
and lost angel tries calling maria but
doesn't get a signal on her phone on
stepping out of the car she witnesses a
couple murdering the owner of a
restaurant they approach her and kill
her as well in the end the siblings are
stranded on their own and have to walk
home alone back at home maria discovers
a red mark on damiana's shoulder she
asks him to get out of the house
instantly because if she gets the
disease too the children will be left
all alone when damiano hesitates she
looks at her phone and finds several
voice messages from angel she
immediately goes looking for the
children and brings them back on the
weekend anna's father comes to visit her
but he is in very bad shape maria
refuses to let him in knowing that he
will put their lives at risk as well
that evening anna sees her father
getting back into the car and falling
unconscious within a few days everyone
gets the disease including maria she
knows she doesn't have many days to live
but the thought of her children being
left alone scares her hence she starts
writing point-by-point steps for the
kids so they can survive in the new
world the first point on the list says
that anna has to take care of herself
and ask her no matter what they have to
stick with each other and face the
challenges together back in the present
a grown anna tells astor that the trees
save them from the outside world and he
can only go out once she is dead unaware
of the concept of death astor wishes for
her to die quickly early in the morning
anna goes to the city to collect
supplies she ends up in a dark room
where she finds a stuffed toy for astor
the room leads her to a church where
many children like her are looking for
food and supplies it turns out that
after the death of all adults the new
world is ruled by children they fight
kill and trade for food anna helps some
girls bring out a block of molded cheese
from under a heavy box she gets into an
argument with them about who gets to
take the cheese they are also joined by
a guy named pietro he has two bottles of
juice that he is willing to trade for
the cheese however anna tricks all of
them and manages to get half a block of
cheese and both bottles of juice
suddenly the place is raided by a group
of rowdy kids named the blue children
they rob and kill people and are on top
of the pyramid in a world without adults
anna and pietro run for their lives to
avoid being robbed they are chased until
they manage to climb a ladder and get to
the other side of a library while
astor's sister is away he keeps himself
busy by running around the jungle
cosplaying as different animals he
notices a jar of olives just outside the
fence and tries to retrieve it with a
stick when he accidentally reaches a
little further from the fence he gets
scared of the monsters and pulls back to
hide from the said monsters he uses a
garbage bag and covers himself before
getting the jar in the city pietro and
anna get away from the blue children and
make friends with each other rumor has
it that the blue children have abducted
some adults who can cure the red fever
with a kiss it is said that they do it
to maintain their rule in the city but
no one believes them on the way pietro
sees a guy on the verge of death with
red fever he stops to help him
experience a painless death but anna
thinks it is useless later he gives her
a ride home on his motorbike anna
refrains from telling him where her
house is but pietro asks her to come by
the beach if she ever wants to meet him
again at home astor goes into his
parents former room where the remains of
maria are still on the bed her skull is
bedazzled and the bed is full of jewelry
the kid brings out the journal and reads
the part where she has explained what
they should do if they find packaged
food it says that they have to read the
label and figure out the expiry date if
they have no option they should smell
the food and if it smells bad boil it
aster smells the jar as advised but
doesn't care about the foul scent a
while later anna comes home and he
excitedly waits for her to show him all
the goods she found she claims that she
fought the monsters to get them just to
make sure he won't try to run outside in
the following scene we see three kids
waking up in a dark cave-like place they
pull on a chain to reveal an adult tied
to the other side it is unclear how the
person isn't dead yet and why the kids
are keeping her alive then we are
introduced to a set of twin brothers
named mario and paulo they own a barter
store that sells maps and foods in
exchange for items most of the time the
brothers sell hair supplements disguised
as red fever pills and fool people they
always have each other's back which is
why they have managed to survive this
long one morning the elder twin paulo
wakes up with a red mark on his body
they check mario as well and find out he
doesn't have any it is clear that paulo
has the disease which means he only has
a few more weeks to live they decide to
eat all of their food rations and make
the next week the best one of their
lives as his last wish paulo claims that
he wants to eat ice cream they have all
the ingredients needed except for a
refrigerator paulo suggests mario dig a
hole in the basement and make it a
seller after paula's death he can still
use it to make ice cream and sell it to
people in the woods we see anna and
astor running around playing and having
fun anna has finally learned to love her
brother the next morning she leaves to
collect supplies yet again but this time
she makes her way to the beach hoping to
meet pietro as she had expected she
finds him in a trailer they swim
together and spend the rest of the day
talking pietro also has a liquid on him
that makes people high the duo ingest it
and lay around the beach looking at each
other it turns out they met each other
before the epidemic when anna was dared
to kiss him in middle school while she
is enjoying her day astor is organizing
a party of his own in the woods he
lights a bunch of stuff on fire that
creates dense smoke the dangerous blue
children are walking down a path near
the woods they see the smoke rising and
follow the path to inspect where it is
coming from astor is wearing his
mother's dress and running around the
house when the blue children barge in
they don't do him any harm but take away
all the supplies in the house a girl
even brings out maria's skull and makes
fun of it the leader of the thugs calls
astor near the kid is surprised because
all his life he has been told that he
and anna are the only people left on
earth but seeing the robbers in his
house changes everything the leader
finds out astor can read which means he
can be an asset to the group after
cleaning the house of all the supplies
the group makes their way outside the
leader calls astor to join them and he
follows without question however when
they ask him to cross the barbed wire he
refuses scared of the monsters a chase
ensues and ends quickly after astor
climbs a tree as the others ask him to
get down he crawls on the branch and
falls down on the other side of the
barbed wire initially the kid panics and
imagines himself being chased by the
monsters but when he comes back to his
senses it is clear that he has been lied
to his entire life after finding out the
truth he follows the group without
hesitation a few hours later anna
returns home and is in utter shock to
see the condition of the house but she
is the most worried about her little
brother who has gone missing the ashy
blue paint on the walls makes it clear
that it was raided by the blue children
still she looks for him in the woods and
falls unconscious out of exhaustion in
her dreams she gets a vision of her
mother asking her if she is going to
look for astor as soon as anna wakes up
she packs her bag and leaves on a search
for her brother firstly she meets pietro
and asks him where she can find the blue
kids since he used to live near them he
knows they will be somewhere in bagheria
anna blames him for being the reason for
astor's disappearance before storming
away she then goes to the twins shop to
exchange batteries for a map to bagheria
mario receives her and asks her to prove
that she is not infected when she proves
it by lifting her top he lets her in the
guy then reveals that he has captured a
blue children member who is in the back
room desperate to find out about her
brother anna believes him and follows
him however mario betrays her and pushes
her into the sticky floor the episode
ends as anna struggles to get up and he
laughs at her
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching